[Music]
okay we're here with dr. Mike Lehmann at
the Air s in Brookings South Dakota and
like you have a talk that you like to
give about an underwear demo an
underwear experiment you did the summer
we'd love to hear about it
well sure I guess I'm gonna backtrack
just a little bit before I introduce the
Younger wear which everybody's waiting
for and talk to you a little bit about
this field experiment behind us is a
field experiment with plots containing
different rotations of corn and soybean
either corn and soybean by itself or
corn and soybean with other crops in
terms of a four year rotation and this
experiment has been going on for 16
years so 16 years these rotational
treatments have been in place and in
this case by adding diversity and taking
a two-year corn and soybean rotation
which is this plot right here and over
here this plot of corn here is a four
year corn pea winter wheat soy rotation
we've added diversity into the system
and this diversity is diversity of crops
but it's also diversity of crop residues
diversity of root exudates from these
crops diversity of root architecture in
the soil and so diversity is really the
focus crop rotational diversity is the
focus of this experiment and why do we
care about rotation crop rotation we've
done a number of long-term Studies on
these particular plots and what we've
shown is the four year rotation actually
produces about 25% less nitrous oxide so
you lose 25 percent less nitrogen as
nitrous oxide from the plots so that
nitrogen stays in the ground where the
plants can use it later
they also
with the forward rotation we were able
to increase the soil organic matter
about 25% over a two-year corn and
soybean rotation and I forgot to mention
all these plots are no-till so they're
all no-till and then they've had they
have a treatment crop cropping system
treatment of rotation and so then the
third finding we have the nitrous oxide
and the soil organic carbon are all
better situated with the four-year
rotation but also the soybean in the
four-year rotation has 25% higher yields
than it does in the corn soybean meal or
tation so all across the board whether
it be nutrients soil organic carbon or
yields we're seeing better performance
by the four-year system you know I can
tell you about this stuff and I can show
you the data but there's not very many
visual displays or I can show you the
difference between a porn and two-year
rotation and so it'll give you an idea
of how fast decomposition occurs in the
soil
you